beides geht mit mir nicht warum nicht
wir haben bereits jetzt die höchste
Steuer- und Abgabenquote unserer
Geschichte im nächsten Jahr wird der
deutsche Gesamtstaat zum ersten Mal mehr
als eine Billionen Euro Einnahmen haben
trotzdem reicht es nicht für die
Ausgaben das zeigt auch wir haben ein
Ausgabe und kein Einnahmeproblem und auf
der anderen Seite bei den Schulden
können wir ebenfalls nicht weitermachen
wie bisher das nicht nur kein Aussetzen
der ist nicht nur ist von nicht nur von
der Verfassung nicht erlaubt es wäre
auch ökonomisch nicht klug wenn die
Zinsen so stark steigen dass von 4 auf
40 Milliarden der Kapital Dienst und
bindet dann kann man doch mit dem
Schulden machen nicht weitermachen dann
zahlen wir irgendwann immer mehr Zinsen
und dann strangulieren wir uns wir
müssen also eins tun wir müssen Politik
machen und das bedeutet auch einmal bei
einer Ausgabe zu sagen die ist veraltet
die brauchen wir nicht mehr wir haben
eine neue Ausgabe die ist wichtig
Bildung oder Digitalisierung etwas für
die Familien zu tun das ist uns wichtig
deshalb muss das alte weichen